era muito bom
mas o que se viu no fiel como
caco é imaginem que estão em nossa casa
e amanhã janela e sentem o calor só
lembro de cada saca fora e senti o vento
batendo na cara
essa é a vossa energia foi isso que
motivou a desenvolver um novo conceito
imaginem que temos um uma mangueira com
água para simplificar o processo de
compreensão
tivemos uma maneira com água evitar um
certo caudal e apontados por um motor
nenhum contou desta manhã
estamos a captar água e ela vai rolar
com uma certa irritação
agora imagine peguei minha mãe pega na
madeira perto o fluxo global até pode
ser menor mas vocês apontam para a ponta
do torpor aponta da barra
vamos obter uma maior rotação essa foi a
ideia base que eu tive
estamos todos o problema depois é
concretizá-las arranjar a melhor maneira
de escutar o áudio
a partida pode parecer certas idéias
parecem são um sucesso
nós temos por exemplo o exemplo dos
irmãos rights watch para quem não é quem
sabe
inventaram o avião parece uma coisa
altamente hotel e que seria o sucesso
instantâneo hora depois o exército
americano convencido que esse vício
sozinhos perceber o potencial do avião
apresentaram a idéia e austero governo o
avião ia pra usar é e os viam o exército
como um potencial máximo
o do exército aí não viu qualquer uso do
avião ou seja há certas dimensões que
são à frente do seu tempo e as pessoas
não têm capacitado para para perceber
isso
ao traçar os inventores as pessoas que
estão é inovar é em mim uma página
espírito muito maior desde que eu sou
essa história é normal é preciso do
caminho
no início não só tem um objetivo e como
o ricardo falou há pouco tempo
imagina que vai ser assim e ponto frio
quero ver o conceito inicial mas não
sabia qual era a melhor forma de
executar o que aconteceu já está a
pensar num projecto novo
as minhas ideias e e melhor que tem que
fazer
ora alguém é uma idéia é imaginar
aposto que muita gente já tentou iniciar
um negócio imaginam que é só burocracia
está envolvido a volta isso agora
imaginem uma idéia as pessoas não
entendem a 0
qual é a motivação uma pessoa consegue
ter conseguido aguentar
é eu confesso que tive noite
completamente claro
pensei em ganhar uma picareta tirar
desta vez de cabeça tipo vai ver tua
vida não é emprego trabalhar para o
outro é mesmo muito grave mas só tem
sido e não sei porque sempre arranjar
forças para conseguir continuar será o
concurso faz parte sim
as minhas irmãs por exemplo dizem que
desde pequeno era muito poupadinho e
precisava de dinheiro sujo
por isso a gestão do dinheiro pra mim é
algo que eu já esteja sempre fui eu subi
no caixa uma questão de educação dos
meus pais
o livro não fui muito pressionado com a
ter boas notas
a questão não foi esse o caso foi
bastante livre
eu sempre tive os meus projetos à parte
sempre sentimos necessidade de trabalhar
porque quando fiz 18 anos podia limitar
uma adaga passear ver as meninas e
talvez mas à parte disso
sempre senti uma necessidade de ter mais
projetos eu posso dizer que fui músico
quem vai dizer se a música em casamentos
foi só na pasta
organizar espetáculos foi produtor de
cerveja coisas não sei porque 107 anos é
chegar a uma questão de importância
quer dizer eu sou bom em matemática no
12º
é posso dizer que a minha primeira
patente é sobre um algoritmo matemático
foi contou o voto e industrial
aposto que traz aqui minha professora
o hotel viu na televisão web o estrigas
ia fazer universidade que as notas foi
sempre ativo projetos à parte e cultivei
outras valências que ora considero muito
importante exemplo a música sempre um
deu um queijo tomate de frente ou seja
eu sou um engenheiro formação base
criativa na maneira com engenheiro
olha olha eu vou fazer aquilo que pensa
é essa é minha filosofia acreditar que é
possível desenvolver 11 desenvolver um
potente que existiam eram um potente
apresentar uma empresa nacional e uma
versão um desenho de uma peça e desenhei
ao time do parafuso encaixe turetta em
diante e uma altura em um lago espécie
então lançado colá lo
e o enterro da gata em costume é mais
tarde
mais tarde sai vira uma revista pessoal
ect cansava o ciclismo a rua boa vista e
vejo exatamente ao time do parafuso
encaixe tudo exatamente igual à que o
selecionado na cabeça e no papel estava
guardado
depois de ferver e isto é mesmo igual
exatamente igual e está trata-se do
ex-goleiro mais avançado que existe no
momento
a partir daí eu pensei afinal não sou um
pouco assim interesse em começar a
acreditar mais em mim próprio é uma
questão fox muito importante é o que o
vôo ou a mudança de atitude também aos
27 anos tive um problema muito grave mas
foi a pensar não sou indestrutível eu
vou estar aqui por exemplo sempre achei
paulo é melhor aproveitar enquanto estou
com algumas única é então para não ter
dor de costas envolve um programa
específico e teoria é que num desporto
durans promove o chamado vereadores mas
a fox
estamos no nosso melhor momento não há
um compartimento koff
então aí a altura ideal pra trazer
idéias surgirem e resolvemos os
problemas foi em cima da bicicleta que
eu resolvi quase tudo ou a treinar no
ginásio é e alterou radicalmente a minha
vida
serão jogos e passei é executar aquilo
que eu queria seja zero isto faço não
voltar por exemplo poder de idéia
ou seja foi nesse ambiente já tinha sido
meu foco já tinha já estava a treinar já
de cabeça já executava é chatinha
desenvolvida tal aplicação industrial
para controlar os valores já estava
habituado a materializar as minhas
ideias
então certo dia estava à vista em vez do
a prémio inovação edp que o futebol e
sair assim
e foi isso que pensa em treinar o foco
dos mandantes
imaginei o conceito base do
funcionamento do dispositivo para isso
eu já expliquei isso não vai
materializar foi igualmente complexo mas
a ideia base serviços gosuen primeiro
produto o blog the ask trabalhava no
desenvolvimento do produto é muito fácil
é uma impressora
imagine uma pessoa só tem uma idéia
desenha uma peça
achei estranho o princípio básico
funcionava e logo a fatura em vieira e o
projeto foi um dos finalistas foi apenas
o começo do ano é nada isso é parte do
terrorismo não só quando está a criar ea
libertadores
estava a partir daí arranjar
financiamento é parte mais difícil todos
estamos a falar para tentar convencer
alguém olha a meios 200 mil a 300 mil
euros para desenvolver isto é é muito
difícil nós temos que ter aquilo muito
bem estruturado na altura era
completamente ver nessas perto e tive
que que faltou prender mata coisas bem
lá consegui um programa da cotec que
existia é quase 500 da empresas serem
criadas a partir do zero ou seja só um
conceito se instalasse no diário e então
conseguir financiamento para apoiar o
desenvolvimento da idéia de
desenvolvimento da idéia mas que mente
fixá-lo um ano em uma sala sozinho com
os tampões é fazer do site
basicamente tenho uma idéia fazia um
design fazer durante um ano
possíveis alterações ao design até obter
o produto final
o caminho foi mais assim vocês não não é
linear nem nada que se pareça com isto o
processo é é contínuo
como podem ver aqui este é o produto
final
na altura em que apresentar o produto
o de uma fase muito crítica
temos 11 11 200 mil euros que podem ver
o que está ali
basicamente é um avião que está é um
avião voava contrário só com o site
sítio e ao final podem imaginar que 200
mil renas desenvolver um avião é muito
pouco seja o primeiro
todos os eventos certificações parte
elétrica de compósitos moldes seja muito
muito complicado e depois o princípio
é o design da peça era puramente
funcional não sei como é que as pessoas
iam reagir à estratégia que o que eu
ganhei foi vou fazer primeiro uma
rolagem aos arquitetos fazer muitas
viagens os arquitetos mostrarem a outra
margem
não ela não gostaram entretanto para ele
esta é esta é a instalação na marina
quer no porto e final de adesão à
comunicação social
é nessa altura o projeto veio nós no 1º
primeiro dia seus mais de mil e mails só
você querer comprar e instalar e depois
aconteceu outra coisa fantástica que é o
player de portugal e os portugueses no
mundo consegue ser chamadas de todo
mundo por 13 e agora tenho nem quero
jogar aqui e fiquei completamente
arrepiava center o poder que portugal
tem e os portugueses
o mundo tem um futuro acredita e estão
em bons cargos sem vencer